well let's talk to the minister for
apprenticeships and skills
jillian keegan good to see you this
morning look testing traces has cost
what 37 billion pounds so far there's
been criticism of it
throughout and now these figures showing
only 18
of people who have symptoms or even
bothering to
to get a test i mean the system just
isn't working at all
is it well i don't i don't think you can
say that i mean 9.6 million people
have actually been traced and we're
doing millions and millions of tests a
day
we're collecting a lot of data from
those tests as well uh 6.4 million have
been contact traced as well
and yeah i mean you know is the system
perfect no it's not because it relies
obviously on people doing the right
thing it relies on people getting a test
and it relies on people uh obviously
isolating if they're
they're positive so it's not perfect
system but it's certainly a very
effective system and you know there's a
lot of people who have
um you know taken tests now and continue
to take tests every day including
um school school children and those
going to college and teachers etc
now taking a couple of tests a week yeah
but we are in this situation as well
where people are not isolating
in the right way now some people may
just not want to
we sort of all understand the
frustration if you like but there is a
definite argument as well to say some
people just financially
can't afford to isolate do we need to
start looking at
paying people to isolate to provide some
sort of financial support to do it
well there is some financial support to
isolate which is 500 pounds
for the period now obviously you could
talk about whether that's enough or not
but there is a payment
there uh to support those who who
isolate
it you know of course it's a difficult
you know we've been at this for over a
year now
uh you know people have had to isolate
possibly several times
i mean i've only done it myself once but
sometimes you know you will have done it
several times and it
it can be a pain but you know it is
important we are all in this together
you know we are vaccinating our way out
of this uh
really really successfully but we have
to be cautious and we have to still
follow uh these guidelines so you know
get a test if you have any symptoms
get a test if you've been asked to by
your employer and you know
isolate if you if you are if you're
testing positive
you must isolate it really is important
it's important for everybody
all the people that we all care about
it's important that you do so
and this might be so you forgive me but
you say get a test if asked to
buy your employer we just saw that
report about pimlico plumbers
do you then support the right of an
employer to say you can only work if
you've
had a vaccine we'll only implore you
if i have if you have a vaccine is is is
that a move you you think is sensible
well there's um some well there's pros
and cons obviously to this
approach and it is quite complex as your
report outlined
um and we will be getting some um
some reports on this something that
they're looking at it at the moment on i
think the fifth of april it's due back
um to michael go for him to look at the
pros and cons of this i mean obviously
individual businesses
will make their their individual um
decisions as well but more broadly
um there'll be some more information
coming in april on on what we should do
about that based on the pros and cons i
mean we can all see aspects of why that
would be a good idea but we can also see
the difficulties as well so the
the the analysis and looking at the the
benefits versus the uh
consequences they'll uh we'll receive on
the fifth of april
uh can i ask you about the the race
report because um
yesterday obviously we were talking to
the minister and he hadn't actually seen
it in full because it hadn't been
uh fully published it has now um
the shadow secretary of state for women
inequalities has said
the government must urgently explain how
they came to publish
content we know it's independent but
published content
which glorifies the slave trade and
immediately dissociate themselves
from these remarks well it doesn't
glorify the the
slave trade it is an independent report
and obviously we have the report as of
11 a.m yesterday and we'll obviously be
looking at it's 285 pages
um i would suggest that the most
important thing that your
your viewers get is to actually read the
report and not the reports of the report
but if you uh look at what you know it
did recognize the inhumanity of slavery
it did recommend uh make many
recommendations about how we educate and
teach young people about
slavery i mean there are 10
commissioners here
um who have an awful lot of experience i
was very impressed i don't really know
the
the people but when you look at the the
the the commissioners and
you know the experiences they have i
think it's very important not to dismiss
them because they have
gone to a lot of time a lot of effort
collected a lot of evidence spoken to a
lot of people
and you know this report is less than 24
hours old
so i suggest we all report read it and
and read it carefully because
what it tries to do is get to some
implementable actions
and i've looked at the 24
recommendations some of them are in my
own area for apprenticeships as well
and i think that's the most important
thing to look and see
what policies we can do to alter
disparate
disparities in this country you know we
we definitely have to level up and we
have to level up across the country
and we have to make sure we remove
barriers to people um who
suffer from some disparities and
inequality in the country